- [Voiceover] We've
already made several videos
over evolution,
and just to remind ourselves
what evolution is talking about,
it's the change in heritable traits
of a population over generations.
And a lot of times, you'll
hear people say evolution
and Natural Selection
really in the same breath,
but what we wanna make a little
bit clear in this video is
that Natural Selection is
one mechanism of evolution.
It's the one most talked about
because it is viewed as
the primary mechanism.
Natural Selection.
But what we're gonna talk about
in this video is another
mechanism called Genetic Drift.
So there's Natural Selection,
and there is Genetic Drift.
Now we've done many videos
on Natural Selection,
but it's this idea that you
have variation in a population,
you have different heritable traits,
and I'm gonna depict those
with different colors here.
We have a population of
living circles here, (laughs)
and they could come in
blue or maybe magenta.
Maybe they come in another variation too,
maybe there is yellow circles,
and Natural Selection is all about
which of these traits are
most fit for the environment
so that they can reproduce.
So there might be something
about being, say, blue,
that allows those circles
to reproduce faster,
or to be less likely to
be caught by predators,
or to be able to stalk prey better.
Even if they're only slightly
more likely to reproduce,
over time, over many generations,
their numbers will increase and dominate,
and the other numbers are less likely,
or the other trait is
less likely to survive,
and so we will have this Natural Selection
for that blue trait.
So this is all about traits
being the fittest traits.
Now Genetic Drift is also
change in heritable traits
of a population over generations,
but it's not about the
traits that are most fit
for an environment are the
ones that necessarily survive.
Genetic Drift is really about random.
Random changes.
Random changes,
and a good example of that
I have right over here
that we got from,
I'll give proper credit,
this is from OpenStax College Biology,
and this shows how Genetic
Drift could happen.
So right over here,
I'm showing a very small
population of 10 rabbits,
and we have the gene for color,
and we have two versions of that gene,
or we could call them two alleles.
You have the capital B version,
and you have the lower case B,
and capital B is dominant.
This is kind of a very Mendelian example
that we're showing here.
And so if you have two
of lower case genes,
two of the white alleles,
you're going to be white.
If you have two of the brown
alleles, the capital Bs,
you're going to be brown,
and if you're a heterozygote,
you're still going to be brown.
So as you can see here, there
are several heterozygotes
in this fairly small population.
But if you just count the capital Bs
versus the lower case Bs,
you see that we have an
equal amount of each.
And so the frequency,
if you were to pick a random
allele from this population,
you're just as likely
to pick a capital B than a lower case B.
Even though the phenotype,
you see a lot more brown,
but these six brown here
have both the upper case B
and the lower case B.
Now let's say they're in a population
where whether you are brown
or whether you are white,
it confers no advantage.
There's no more likelihood
of surviving and reproducing
if you're brown than white,
but just by chance,
by pure random chance,
the five bunnies on the top are the ones
that are able to reproduce,
and the five bunnies on
the bottom are not the ones
that are able to reproduce.
And you might be saying hey,
why did I pick those top five?
I didn't pick them, I'm
just giving an example.
It could've been the bottom five.
It could've been only these two,
or the only two white ones were the ones
that were able to reproduce.
It's by pure random chance,
or it could be because of
traits that are unrelated
to the alleles that we are talking about.
But from the point of
view of these alleles,
it looks like random chance.
And so in the next generation,
those five rabbits reproduce
and you could have a situation like this,
and just by random chance, as you can see,
the capital B allele
frequency has increased
from 50% of the alleles
in the population to 70%.
And then it could be
another random chance,
and I'm not saying this is
necessarily going to happen.
It could happen the other way.
It could happen even though
that first randomness happened,
maybe now all of a sudden
this white rabbit is able
to reproduce a lot,
but maybe not.
Maybe these two brown rabbits
that are homozygous for
the dominant trait are able
to reproduce,
and one again it has
nothing to do with fitness.
And so they're able to reproduce,
and then all of a sudden,
the white allele is completely
gone from the environment.
And the reason why this happened isn't
because the white allele somehow
makes the bunnies less fit.
In fact, it might have
even conferred a little bit
of an advantage.
It might have been,
from the environment that the
bunnies are in point of view,
it might have even been a better trait,
but because of random chance,
it disappears from the population.
And the general idea
with the Genetic Drift,
so once again, just to compare,
Natural Selection,
you are selecting,
or the environment is selecting traits
that are more favorable for reproduction,
while Genetic Drift is random changes.
Random changes in reproduction
of the population.
Now, as you can imagine,
I just gave an example with 10 bunnies,
and what I just described
is much more likely
to happen with small populations.
So much more likely.
More likely
with small populations.
And we have videos on
statistics on Khan Academy,
but the likelihood of this happening
with 10 bunnies versus the likelihood
of what I just described happening
with 10 million bunnies is very different.
It's much more likely to
happen with a small population.
So a lot of the contexts
of Genetic Drift are
when people talk about small populations.
In fact, many times Biologists are worried
about small populations specifically
because of Genetic Drift.
For random reasons, you
could have less diversity,
less variation in your population,
and even favorable traits
could be selected for
by random chance.
There's two types of Genetic
Drift that are often called out
that cause extreme
reductions in population,
and significantly reduce the populations.
One is called the Bottleneck Effect.
Let me write this down.
So the Bottle,
Bottleneck,
the Bottleneck Effect,
and then the other is
called the Founder Effect.
Do that over here.
The Founder,
Founder Effect.
They are both ideas
where you have significant
reduction in population
for slightly different reasons.
Bottleneck Effect is you have
some major disaster or event
that kills off a lot of the population,
so only a little bit of the
population is able to survive.
And the reason why it's
called Bottleneck is imagine
if you had a bottle here.
If you had a bottle here and, I dunno,
inside of that bottle,
you had marbles of different colors.
So you have some yellow marbles,
you have some magenta marbles,
you have some, I don't know, blue marbles.
These are the colors
that I tend to be using.
You have some blue marbles,
so you have a lot of variation
in your original population.
But if you think about
pouring them out of a bottle,
maybe somehow there's some major disaster,
and only two of these survive,
or let's say only four of these survive,
and so you could view that as,
"Well, what are the marbles
that are getting poured
"out of the bottle?"
It's really just a metaphor.
Obviously, we're not putting populations
of things in bottles.
But after that disaster,
only a handful survive,
and they might not have any traits
that are in any way more
desirable or more fit
for the environment than everything else,
but they just by random chance,
because of this disaster,
they are the ones that survived.
And so all of a sudden,
you have a massive reduction
not only in the population,
but also in the variation
in that population,
and many alleles might
have even disappeared,
and so you have an extreme form
of Genetic Drift actually occurring.
Another example is Founder Effect,
which is the same idea of a
population becoming very small,
but the Founder Effect isn't
because of a natural disaster.
Let's say you had a population.
Once again, you have a
lot of different alleles
in that population.
You have a lot of variation,
you have a lot of variation
in that population.
So let me just keep coloring it.
You have a lot of variation
in this population,
and let's say that,
you know, they're all
hanging out in their region,
and maybe, you know,
they are surrounded by mountains.
I'm just making this up as I go,
but let's say a couple of
these blue characters were
out walking one day,
and they maybe get separated
from the rest of their population.
Maybe they discover a little
undiscovered mountain pass,
and they go settle a new
population someplace.
So that's why it's called
the Founder Effect.
These are the founders
of a new population,
and once again, by random chance,
they just have a lot less variation.
They're a smaller population
and they happen to be disproportionately
or all blue in this case,
and so now this population
is going to (mumbles)
Just the process of this was Genetic Drift
where many alleles will have disappeared
because you have such a small
population of blues here.
And also because you have
such a small population,
you're likely to have
even more Genetic Drift.
So it's a really interesting
thing to think about.
Evolution and Natural
Selection are often talked
about hand in hand,
but Natural Selection isn't the
only mechanism of Evolution.
You also have Genetic Drift,
which is really about,
not selecting for favorable traits,
it is about randomness.